department as well as dr mary hamill
senior technical officer malaria vaccine
implementation program and dr david
schellenberg scientific advisor for the
global malaria program
speakers will first give their remarks
and then we'll begin the q a with
journalists
when we open the floor to the media q a
please enter your name and media outlet
and to ask a question please click ray's
hand
and when you're called upon of course
don't forget to unmute
and please only one question per
journalist
and a reminder that as this is a press
conference related to rtss please keep
your questions related to malaria and
the rtss vaccine if you have questions
about covid19 you can ask them in our
presser tomorrow so with that i will now
give the floor to dr tedros the floor is
yours dr tedros
thank you thank you carla
dear colleagues and friends
as some of you may know
i started my career as a malaria
researcher and i longed for the day
that we would have an effective vaccine
against this ancient
and terrible disease
and today is that day
an historic day
today wha is recommending the broad use
of the world's first malaria vaccine
this recommendation is based on results
from an ongoing pilot program in ghana
kenya and malawi that has reached more
than 800 000 children since 2019
this long-awaited malaria vaccine is a
breakthrough for science
child health and malaria control
using this vaccine in addition to
existing tools to prevent malaria could
save
tens of thousands of young lives each
year
we have made incredible progress in the
fight against malaria in the past two
decades
since 2000
malaria does have fallen by more than
half and we have succeeded in
eliminating malaria from many parts of
the world
but globally
progress has stalled at an unacceptably
high level
with more than 200 million cases
and 400 000 days every year
two thirds of those days are children
under five in africa
who has said consistently that we need
new tools to get malaria control back on
track
two years ago
who and our partners began a pilot
program to roll out this vaccine in
ghana kenya
and malawi
here is
what we have learned
this vaccine can be delivered through
child health clinics
by ministries of health and readily
reach children at high coverage levels
community demand for the vaccine is
strong
it has broad reach to children including
the most vulnerable
who may not use a bed net thereby
expanding access to preventive measures
to children at risk
it is safe
it significantly reduces
life-threatening severe malaria
and we estimate it to be highly cost
effective
this is a powerful new tool
but like covet 19 vaccines
it's not the only tool
vaccination against malaria does not
replace or reduce the need for other
measures
including bad nets
or seeking care for fever
of course
the key to any public health andover of
this size and scope
is partnership
i thank the children
families and communities who have
participated in this historic pilot
program
i thank the ministries of health of
ghana kenya and malawi for their
leadership in embarking on these pilot
programs
which have continued despite copied 19.
i thank the researchers in africa
who generated the data and insights that
informed this decision
this is a vaccine developed in africa
by african scientists
and we're very proud
i thank
glaxosmithline
and many research partners for creating
the vaccine and puzz for bringing it
from discovery through development with
support from the bill and melinda gates
foundation
and i thank gavi
the global fund and unit aid
who funded the pilot programs and the
evaluations
malaria has been with us for millennia
and the dream of a malaria vaccine has
been a long-held
but unattainable dream
today
the rtss malaria vaccine
more than 30 years in the making
changes the course of public health
history
we still have a very long road to travel
but this is
a long stride down that road
this vaccine is a gift to the world
but its value will be felt most in
africa
because that's where the burden of
malaria is greatest
it's now my pleasure to welcome my
sister and colleague dr shiri moeti
who's regional director for africa to
talk about the difference this vaccine
will make on the continent
dr moyetti you have the floor
thank you very much
dr ted rose director general that was
the director general of the world health
organization hailing and historic day
as he announces the first malaria
vaccine could be rolled out to billions
as experts have given it an approval and
the potential there to save hundreds of
thousands of lives
across the african continent um
let's talk to uh thomas moore who's with
us now thomas this is a huge
announcement from the world health
organization it certainly is you heard
the director general saying that he had
started his scientific career as a
malaria researcher and he had been
hoping all the way along that he would
see the day in his career where there
was a vaccine against this this terrible
disease
and today is that day he said that we
now have a vaccine it's not hugely
effective it prevents around three out
of ten severe cases but so great are the
numbers so severe is the disease that
would still
save the lives of tens of thousands of
people every year and most of these are
children under the age of five one child
every two minutes dies from malaria
almost all of them in sub-saharan africa
now
over the last uh 20 years there's been
this huge effort to try and get bed nets
to people because that is a very cheap
way of preventing malaria but that
effort has stalled and so we're still
seeing large numbers of deaths and
that's why a vaccine is desperately
needed and this this vaccine the squirts
has been tried and tested in three
countries ghana
kenya and and malawi and it has been
shown to be effective there even in
areas where there are a lot of bed nets
being used so now the who is saying
let's roll it out it will need to be
assessed by gavi who are the the main
vaccine funders and once that's secured
then you can expect this to be rapidly
rolled out that's going to be the next
big question isn't it the rollout i mean
we have experience from talking about
that very recently with the uh covert
vaccination and we know about
vaccinations getting to developing
countries can be very difficult those
are the next steps that the world health
organization are going to have to face
absolutely right but what they've done
in kenny malawi and ghana is shown that
this can be given to
young babies this is given from the age
of five months up to 15 18 months
there's four doses
but they can be given at the same time
as measles tb all those other vaccines
that children will have
and people do accept it they see that
this is something that they really want
so uptake has been very high so that's
really encouraging uh that this could be
rolled out further but even more
exciting there's a vaccine which is
being developed by the same oxford
university group that developed the
covet vaccine and it's twice as
effective just think of what that would
mean in terms of rolling back malaria
and that's why that
uh dr tedros said at the end there that
this is a gift to the world that that we
still have a long road to travel but
we're a long way down that road now yeah
and also just an interesting fact the
world has never had a vaccine against a
human parasite not just against malaria
i mean that just puts into context what
a huge
huge
vaccines are generally against viruses
some against bacteria but parasites are
much more complex they can slip away
from the immune system they use a
combination of stealth and deception and
that's how the malaria parasite gets
into the liver this vaccine stops it uh
well it's an incredible feat and a huge
announcement today from the world health
organization uh that they are
recommending the broad use of the
world's first malaria vaccine
for children it's a major breakthrough
um
and thomas as i said what happens now
this is the announcement we talk about
the next steps in in the rollout but
it's going to take a while for this to
sink into for the scientific community
and everyone that's been working towards
this yes the next step is that the wha
board needs to approve it once they've
done that then as i say the gabby the
the vaccine alliance will want to to
make sure that they've got the money to
actually roll this out the millions of
doses that are going to be needed very
shortly okay thomas more thank you uh
well that is going to uh at least the
news agenda
this evening mark austin is going to be
here with more details that press
conference with the world health
organization continuing a lot of
questions being asked of the director
general of the world health organization
understandably uh we'll bring you a
roundup of that at five o'clock with
mark austin but just to reiterate the
world health organization announcing the
first vaccine against malaria could save
hundreds of thousands of lives across
the african continent more coming up
next